nadine verkehrn believes that the
gaming industry is
missing out on a large market for women the 29-year-old
founded the internet portal games make
up a platform exclusively for
the women in the
scene women don’t need to be rescued
women i’m sometimes a
car cracker or  a woman also just wants to run
around and have some
fun and laughter she
might want cyberpunk or content there
are so many things where you
can keep opening your eyes
you can do something about it, yes you can do something about
it
, for example by developing games where
you increase that  paying attention to what women
like, what women want and where you can identify
with what kind of thing
and what game
they can identify with and
maybe also
bring more women into the industry so you can see
that there are relatively few women in the
industry  are that I also today,
for example, on the torment but looked around
those are yes  many men here
and always a bit fewer women
and there also to ensure that
there are youngsters that more women come in that the
view can simply be broadened
they had no factors where they could
throw up we start
it stupid that I poop or  where you
maybe didn't start or is it
actually we heard about things
we that you
had to go out as a yes and talk about having to keep your eyes open as a
woman on some
other platforms and if i just
hear the word out loud you don't just have to come
out  because you're a woman that
sounds somehow a
bit crazy